bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
richissounac Premier ministre
britannique à 42 ans il est à la fois le
plus jeune chef du gouvernement du pays
et le premier
issu de la diversité ancien banquier
d'affaires il est fortuné brexitter ex
ministre l'économie de Boris Johnson
Richie sounaque va devoir redresser un
pays en proie à une forte inflation et
au bord de la récession il voudrait je
cite réparer les erreurs de listrot et
résoudre la crise économique profonde
c'est ce qu'il a affirmé dans son
premier discours le ministre des
Finances du Rémi Hunt qui avait été
nommé en catastrophe par listrot pour
calmer la tempête financière et
maintenue à son poste ainsi que ben moi
là ça la défense Joe Biden a qualifié de
révolutionnaire ça désignation Emmanuel
Macron l'a bien sûr félicité et promis
de continuer à œuvrer ensemble alors
troisième chef du gouvernement depuis le
début de l'année comment va-t-il garder
le Parti conservateur uni et incarner la
stabilité à deux ans des prochaines
élections quelles politiques va-t-il
mettre en oeuvre face à l'inflation
brexitter quelle sera sa relation avec
les Européens et avec le reste du monde
peut-il rétablir la confiance et bien on
va poser toutes ces questions à nos
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir mes
côtés Nicolas Jara jolie bonsoir vous
êtes membre du lever parti bienvenue à
vous bienvenue dans le débat en face de
vous poltomson bonsoir vice-président
des conservateurs britanniques à Paris
bienvenue à vous également Catherine
Mathieu est avec nous et que les
mystallo FCE bienvenue et puis nous
avons en direct de belles fast par Skype
Viviane gravy bonsoir enseignante
chercheuse spécialistes des questions
européennes à la Queen's University of
Belfast
à 42 ans il devient donc Premier
ministre et sud de la classe moyenne il
est passé par Oxford puis Stanford aux
États-Unis ses grands-parents viennent
du Penjab en Inde il est à la fois donc
le plus jeune chef du gouvernement du
Royaume-Uni et aussi le premier issu de
la diversité son portrait avec David
Gilbert
sa démission en juillet dernier de son
poste de chancelier de l'Échiquier avait
porté un coup fatal au gouvernement de
Boris Johnson qu'il a souhaité remplacer
dans la foulée battu par les stress lors
du scrutin interne du Parti conservateur
au mois de septembre Régis sunac n'aura
eu qu'à attendre un mois et demi pour
tenter de nouveau sa chance le
Royaume-Uni est un grand pays mais nous
sommes confrontés à une profonde crise
économique c'est pourquoi je me présente
pour être le leader du Parti
conservateur et votre prochain Premier
ministre je veux redresser notre
économie unir notre partie et agir pour
notre pays avant même cette déclaration
de candidatures pour ce nouveau scrutin
Régis sunac a été le premier candidat à
récolter les 100 parrainages nécessaires
à 42 ans celui qui a suivi des cours
dans les prestigieux établissements du
Winchester collège et de l'Université
d'Oxford avant de commencer sa carrière
au sein de la banque Goldman Sachs
accède au poste de Premier ministre
sceptant seulement après son entrée en
politique élu député en 2015 il s'engage
en faveur du brexit réélu en 2017 il
intègre le gouvernement britannique
l'année suivante comme sous secrétaire
d'Ét dans le cabinet de Theresa May il
gravit les échelons au sein du Parti
conservateur devenant secrétaire en chef
du Trésor en 2019 dans le premier
gouvernement de Boris Johnson puis
ministre des Finances en 2020 après la
démission de sagit de David avec la
crise du covid richissounac devient une
figure centrale de la vie politique
britannique notamment lorsqu'il annonce
un grand plan de relance à l'été 2020
j'annonce aujourd'hui au total 30
milliards de livres pour aider le peuple
britannique les emplois Britanniques et
les entreprises britanniques qui a
traversé ce moment sa popularité est
entachée au printemps dernier après
plusieurs révélations sa femme
multimillionnaire ne paye pas ses impôts
en Grande-Bretagne richiss una lui a
détenu une carte verte américaine
pendant 19 mois après être devenu
chancelier après s'être mis en retrait
au mois de septembre il est réapparu ces
derniers jours comme le favori pour
occuper le disque Durning Street les
retraits successifs de Boris Johnson
puis de Penny mordante lui ont laissé la
voie libre
je commençais par vous puisque vous
faites partie du Parti conservateur
comment est-ce que vous le qualifiez
c'est un anti Boris Johnson un peu
d'une certaine manière on pourrait dire
cela c'est quelqu'un de très pragmatique
qui qui est connu pour être très sérieux
compétent y compris sur des sujets
éminemment techniques personne
ne conteste l'intelligence de Boris John
mais c'est vrai que il avait une autre
forme d'intelligence qui qui regarde les
les grands sujets mais qui répugnent un
petit peu rentrer dans le dans le détail
des dossiers comme on dit donc
effectivement il y a une différence de
personnalité
la moins pire des solutions pour le
Parti conservateur à titre
on perçoit côté travail
[Musique]
Oxford la City et d'ailleurs
grand classique grand classique et
d'ailleurs depuis Saturne Premier
ministre conservateurs qui ont eu du
succès c'est ceux qui ont passé par ce
milieu donc la tendance pour lui c'est
bien mais bon
c'est quand même le premier issu de la
diversité c'est une importance
sans doute sans doute je ça fait partie
aussi d'une stratégie je crois depuis
Cameron dans le Parti conservateur de
mettre en avant certains une figures de
minorité ethnique pour saper ce que dit
le parti travailliste sur le Parti
conservateur mais
je crois aussi que c'est quand même
quelqu'un issu d'une famille très riche
sa femme comme a dit le clip au début et
la fille d'un milliardaire indien donc
géant de la technologie donc je ne
sais pas si le fait qu'il soit issu de
la diversité comme vous dites soit un
élément si significatif que ça c'est un
vrai libéral Catherine Mathieu on peut
dire ça un brexitter en tout cas de la
première heure de la première heure et
vraie libéral d'ailleurs quand la crise
covid a débuté et que riches un acte
venait de prendre ses fonctions comme
ministre de l'Économie son premier
discours a été de dire au peuple
britannique attendez-vous à ce qu'il y
ait des licenciements et à ce qu'il y a
des faillites d'entreprises ça n'est pas
l'état qui va venir à votre secours et
il a très rapidement changé d'avis comme
le disait le reportage mais parce que
Boris Johnson est intervenu en disant il
faut faire quelque chose là il faut
soutenir les entreprises et les ménages
parce qu'on part dans une grande crise
donc il a su plus orthodoxes que Boris
Johnson selon moi oui oui clairement
dans ces différentes déclarations il est
très orthodoxe mais il a su intégrer
quand il était ministre les souhaits de
Boris Johnson ça c'était vrai aussi pour
d'autres éléments par exemple comme la
taxation des super profits pétroliers au
début Régis un acte n'était pas pour et
finalement il s'est rangé à la vie que
selon lequel il faut se serait bien
quand même de taxer davantage des
entreprises du secteur pétrolier par les
temps dans les temps actuels donc qui
s'est adapté à la situation il est
pragmatique Viane gravé comment le
perçoit-on de belles faces
alors en fait de belles faces ce qui
nous importe avant tout c'est que
normalement nous on a la date de
vendredi le vendredi 28 et le ministre
pour l'Irlande du Nord précédent avait
promis que si nous n'avons pas de
gouvernement à minuit une le vendredi 28
il appellerait à des nouvelles élections
ici et donc la grande question déjà ici
c'est qu'est-ce que va faire régler sous
lac va-t-il changer l'approche vis-à-vis
du gouvernement non irlandais et le fait
qu'on a toujours pas de gouvernement
depuis mai donc va-t-il garder la même
équipe en place pour l'Irlande du Nord
et bien sûr après qu'elle va être sa
relation avec l'Union européenne car ça
bien sûr la relation avec l'Union
européenne va importer énormément sur
qu'est-ce qui se passe ici en termes de
est-ce qu'on réussit à avoir un
gouvernement est-ce qu'on réussit enfin
à appliquer ou à changer le protocole on
va y revenir un pôle Thomson c'est le
troisième Premier ministre tout de même
en même pas six mois est-ce qu'il va
réussir à unifier à garder uni le Parti
conservateur est-ce qu'il va réussir à
incarner la stabilité
c'est une c'est une bonne question je
pense qu'il a de bonnes chances d'y
arriver mais ce ne serait pas une tâche
facile c'est vrai que le Parti
conservateur comme tout grand parti
politique à différentes écoles pensées
différents groupes il est très divisé
aujourd'hui le Parti conservateur
il n'aime pas plus que les républicains
en France par exemple ou même la partie
socialiste en France les Verts
d'ailleurs c'est une signe de santé
qu'il y a de véritables de débats dans
les parties politiques toujours faut-il
que la partie puisse faire des choses et
présenter un programme cohérent aux
électeurs donc
donc il faut pas que les débats dérape
dérape trop je pense qu'il a de bonnes
chances d'y réussir parce que comme on a
déjà fait ressortir d'une part il a été
un brexitor de la première heure ce qui
n'était pas le cas de d'autre part cette
clarté en fait probexit c'est plutôt bon
pour lui au sein du parti oui probable
pour les
conservateur et et d'autre part il est
comme vous avez déjà dit aussi
[Musique]
proche des milieux d'affaires il a
travaillé sax qui est un peu le standard
hors dans le monde de la haute finance
et la fondé son propre fond
d'investissement il n'est pas de famille
riche lui-même il est d'une famille
c'était la classe moyenne très
travailleuse ses parents étaient très
strictes et c'est le cas pour des
parents de son épouse et qu'elle m'ont
très stricte à poussant les enfants à
travailler derrière son beau-père après
mes compréhension lui non plus il est
milliardaire maintenant mais lui aussi
elle a commencé comme un ingénieur dans
une dans une boîte et il a réussi à
bâtir une entreprise qui pèse 100
milliards d'euros c'est vraiment un faut
6 en Inde pardon elle s'appelle
exactement exactement
[Musique]
un peu effectivement issu d'une famille
modeste ça ça rectifie un peu justement
sa richesse d'aujourd'hui qui a failli
lui coûter qui lui est un peu coûté
finalement le poste à au moment où il
stresse l'a emporté le semble-t-il je ne
pense pas que ce soit qui lui qui a fait
gagner le stress tu sais parce que je
pense que c'est parce qu'elle avait une
discours
on peut dire qu'il plaisait à la base du
Parti conservateur en disant il faut
absolument passer les impôts
et ne jurait que par cela enfin
alors que lui disait il faut quand même
qu'on œuvre dans le monde réel il faut
être sérieux et regardez exactement et
finalement on a vu après coup que
c'était tout à fait apte comme image
c'est-à-dire que le propos de
la ligne de le stress dans la façon on
peut simpliste dont le formulaire ne
tenait pas la route pas parce que
personne avec d'autres idées étaient
contre le terme tout simplement parce
que devant les marchés financiers
elle a généré une sorte de panique parce
que les investisseurs ont vu que ça se
levait des problèmes concernant les
finances du pays donc voilà les rassurer
Nicolas Gérard joli est-ce qu'il va
rassurer justement faire retrouver la
confiance à ce pays à votre avis
sans doute il y a eu les marchés
la ligne que tout le monde suit sur les
marchés c'est soulevé un tout petit peu
aujourd'hui
c'est tout à fait possible il fait
partie de ces milieux il connaît des
gens donc je vois pas pourquoi pas et
mais voilà je pense que le problème avec
les strolls c'est que les les traders
comment dire en anglais ont vu que tout
cet argent allait au très riche et tout
le monde sait que quand une telle
quantité d'argent va au très riche on
ils investissent pas dans l'économie
réelle la circulation des biens mais
dans les dans les bienfaits fonciers ou
les biens je sais pas comment dire ça en
français les A7 et ça ça fait pas ça ça
fait pas améliorer l'économie dans le
court terme les actions voilà et donc
pour sunnac je crois que il va devoir
chevaucher la limite entre le
le mandat entre guillemets redistributif
de Boy stranson et les sensibilités
libertaires au sens économique libéral
qui est en français dans le Parti
conservateur et c'est ça l'équilibre
qu'il va devoir
réaliser et je sais pas s'il pourra
peut-être c'est pas facilement
au programme des législatives de 2019
par rapport à l'histoire qui avait fait
s'était lancé dans un grand big bang en
baissant tous les impôts et en ne
suivant pas ce qui était dans le
programme des législatives de 2019 donc
ça veut dire que richiss unach va à
priori si ce programme à nouveau
considérer le besoin du leveling up donc
de remonter le niveau des régions du
nord de l'Angleterre qu'il va aussi
revenir sur la décision qui avait pris
d'istrus de relancer la fracturation
l'extraction de gaz de schiste et qu'il
va revenir là-dessus remettre en place
le moratoire qui était dans les dans un
programme des des conservateurs de 2019
et j'espère avoir un programme davantage
orienté vers la neutralité climatique à
l'horizon 2050 ce qui avait complètement
disparu de l'agenda de listrus donc il
se rapprocherait plus du programme de
Boris Johnson de 2019 c'est ce qui
aujourd'hui alors on va justement
l'écouter richessounac parce qu'il a
fait une un premier discours juste après
sa domination son officialisation comme
premier ministre Royaume-Uni il a dit
qu'il voulait réparer les erreurs de
l'histoire on va l'écouter
je reviens de Buckingham Palace où j'ai
accepté la demande de Sa Majesté le Roi
de former un gouvernement son nom
aujourd'hui notre pays fait face à une
profonde crise économique
je veux rendre hommage à ma
prédécesseuse listres elle n'avait pas
tort de vouloir relancer la croissance
du pays
c'est un objectif noble
et j'admire son énergie pour amener des
changements
mais des erreurs ont été commises
le gouvernement que je dirige ne
laissera pas les prochaines générations
vos enfants et petits-enfants avec une
dette à régler que nous aurions été trop
faibles pour payer nous-mêmes
je travaillerai jour et nuit à votre
service
je comprends aussi que j'ai du travail à
faire
pour restaurer la confiance après tout
ce qui est arrivé
Viviane graver c'était un bon début ce
discours alors c'est un début rassurant
mais je voudrais juste revenir un petit
peu sur sur la question des origines
modestes de Régis soudain je pense qu'il
faut rappeler enfin de vue quand on
parle de classement moyenne c'est une
catégorie très large l'école le
Winchester College ou richissounac et
aller à l'école c'est 40 000 livres par
année donc c'est bien sûr c'est une
classe moyenne quand même très
supérieure c'est bien sûr des gens qui
sont boursiers
et tout ça mais néanmoins ce n'est quand
même pas vraiment c'est pas un job
majeur là-dessus pour le milieu
conservateur alors
quand à son discours ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'en effet on a cette
promesse du disque du programme de 2019
le programme de 2019 c'est donc c'est le
programme de Boris avec lequel il a
réussi à avoir une majorité très forte
et sur lesquelles il fait des promesses
très importantes sur l'environnement
mais aussi sur donc vraiment essayer de
gouverner pour tout le Royaume-Uni ce
qui est intéressant quand même problème
c'est que on voit c'est la question
c'est est-ce qu'il va vraiment s'y tenir
ce qu'on sait c'est que aujourd'hui
listrus avait mis en place plusieurs
propositions de loi qui sont déjà dans
la chambre des communes sur le fait de
par exemple de d'enlever toutes les
normes européennes qui sont encore en
place au Royaume-Uni avant la fin
décembre 2023 régie sunac avait fait la
même promesse pendant les pendant
l'élection en juillet va-t-il s'y tenir
ou va-t-il se tenir au programme de
borisent de 2019 on a donc plein de
questions sur toute une série de
politiques publiques où il faut vraiment
vérifier va-t-il en effet vraiment faire
table rase et enlever toutes les
propositions de loi qui avait proposé
qui sera Paul Thompson justement est-ce
qu'il va alors on va regarder quand même
quelques statistiques l'inflation c'est
10% depuis 3 mois au Royaume-Uni donc
c'est quasiment un record en Europe et
manifestement il y a une explosion des
prix aussi des produits de première
nécessité c'est pas seulement les prix
de l'énergie la dette publique elle est
à 98% de PIB alors c'est vrai qu'on est
un peu étonné quand on regarde le
Royaume-Uni et la charge de la dette a
fortement augmenté à cause de cette
inflation et puis effectivement du fait
que le pound que la livre sterling est
baissée elle est de 30 milliards de
livres par an c'est ce que j'ai ce que
j'ai pu lire donc le défi en fait c'est
un petit peu ce que disait Viviane gravé
Paul Thompson il va falloir à la fois
rassurer les marchés tout en protégeant
les Britanniques parce qu'il y a une
flambée des prix donc il faut les
protéger donc dépenser et en même temps
rassurer les marchés donc être orthodoxe
financièrement ça va être compliqué il
va augmenter les impôts c'est ce qu'il
va faire est-ce que ça fait partie du
programme de Boris Johnson de fameux
programme de 2019 c'est une des
questions je pense que
je suis en face raison que il sera
obligé de chevaucher une crête
difficile compliquée
parce que
il est vrai qu'il a dit qu'il allait
suivre le plafond de 2019 vous avez
raison c'est très significatif en même
temps ce ne sera pas facile d'en laisser
circonstances actuelles tout est aussi
une question de
du délai
parce que
exactement
le meilleur scénario pour lui et
l'action en décembre 2024 dans deux ans
il peut se passer des choses la Banque
d'Angleterre prévoit une cinq trimestre
successives de récession ça nous amène
afin à 2023
en deux ans il est possible que la
situation se
retourne et il s'améliore mais je pense
que ce qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit c'est
que
l'électorat britannique est assez
pour pouvoir entendre des messages
un peu un peu difficile par exemple
difficiles là dans son discours les
mettre en place
s'ils sont convaincus que le
gouvernement véritable programme pour
s'attaquer de véritables problèmes
à accepter qu'il faut passer par une
période où on sert la ceinture etc c'est
qu'en 2010 il y avait une élection où le
parti conservateur avait un programme
qui était franchement à base de sous
l'austorité l'austérité et leur
stratégie à l'époque était que les gens
même si c'est pénible comme message
alors
reconnaître le mérite de l'honnêteté de
la
et ils ont une assez bons résultats dans
cette élection
mais marié
différentes ces différentes priorités
c'est sûrement difficile je pense qu'il
y aura des hausses impôts sur les riches
pas sur les personnes
augmenter les impôts sur les riches donc
faire l'inverse
et en ce qui concerne l'impôt sur les
revenus
a déjà dit qu'il conviendrait de
remonter à 25% de titres et je suppose
que donc ça c'est pas les les pauvres ce
sont les sociétés qui qui vont porter
cette charge sur les sociétés et
augmenter l'impôt pour la tranche
supérieure c'est ça Catherine matthieu a
priori
c'est ce qui avait été annoncé il y a
quelques jours par Jérémy Hunt mais il
faut bien voir que quand même
l'essentiel des mesures qui avait été
annoncées avant par listrots allaient
toutes dans le sens de baisse d'impôts
donc là Jérémy on a supprimé certaines
de ces baisses d'impôts mais il reste un
trou d'à peu près 30 milliards de livres
à combler et la grande inconnue
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir qui va
contribuer à réduire
ce trou de 30 milliards ou peut-être
plus d'ailleurs et la crainte avec cette
inflation de 10% que vous avez mentionné
tout à l'heure Stéphanie c'est qu'en
fait on ne revalorise pas les
prestations des revenus les plus faibles
qu'on ne revalorise pas de 10% mais
peut-être que de 5 %, ça c'était le
projet il y a quelques jours donc il y
aurait des pertes de pouvoir d'achat
pour les ménages les plus vulnérables il
y a une crise de l'énergie qui se
poursuit il y a des conditions de vie
qui sont dures pour les ménages
britanniques pour la plupart d'entre
elles un bouclier justement pour les
tarifaire parce que c'était le bouclier
avait été mis en place par listrot donc
ce bouclier il reste en place si rien ne
change au moins 6 mois dans 6 mois il y
aura une étude de la situation pour voir
si on le maintient ou pas alors
évidemment tout dépendra de la situation
sur les marchés du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité dans 6 mois si on est
optimiste et qu'on pense que la
situation géopolitique se sera améliorée
il n'y aura pas de problème pour le
financement des dépenses publiques
britanniques et sur ces questions de
prix de l'énergie mais si on a une
guerre qui se poursuit si les prix
l'énergie continuent à augmenter dans
six mois il faudra bien poursuivre ce
bouclier tarifaire ça annonce de
nouvelles mesures à venir très
probablement donc il savait difficile
pour des gestionnaires effectivement ça
creuse le déficit public Nicolas Gérard
Joly moi j'ai vu que 90% des
établissements scolaires du Royaume-Uni
seront à court de ressources l'année
prochaine enfin c'était écrit dans des
observer en raison de l'explosion des
factures donc comment effectivement
faire une politique d'austérité donc un
bouclier tarifaire d'un côté une
politique d'austérité et puis des
services publics et manifestement même
enfin les écoles vont mal manifestement
c'est ça qui inquiète un peu avec son
discours parce qu'il dit qu'il va
respecter le mandat de 2019 le programme
de 2019 mais il introduit les mêmes
éléments de langage de 2010 à 2015 qui
est de l'austérité il faut
cette métaphore des finances du foyer
comme les finances de la nation et oui
les conservateurs ont eu un bon résultat
en 2010 et 2015 mais en 2017 la
politique d'austérité a été rejetée et
justement c'est en 2019 que la politique
d'austérité est surtout la rhétorique au
moins a été complètement abandonnée par
Boris Johnson et ça a donné le très
grand la très grande majorité de 2019
donc je pour moi c'est pas clair si va
couper dans les quelle dépense de la
rhétorique et quoi relève de du contenu
de ce qu'il va faire pour le moment
c'est il a été premier ministre pour
même pas quelques heures
vous êtes d'accord Viviane graver il y a
un problème de service public et d'école
au Royaume-Uni est-ce que effectivement
il risque de couper encore dans les
dépenses
je pense qu'il y a en effet un gros
problème enfin sur le système de santé
qui souffre quand même beaucoup ou les
attentes maintenant pour juste pour même
avoir une ambulance qui arrive ou
arriver à être traitée en arrivant aux
urgences maintenant plusieurs heures
voire plusieurs jours pour les
ambulances en Angleterre donc on est
quand dans une situation de crise sur
les services publics britanniques mais
l'important quand même on parle beaucoup
du programme de 2019 il faut se rappeler
bien sûr décembre 2019 c'est avant la
pandémie et donc bien sûr dans tous les
cas
le programme de 2019 il peut pas être
appliqué
complètement parce que le monde
d'aujourd'hui quand même très très
différent donc on voit quand même il y a
vraiment donc il va y avoir un certain
devoir de choisir certaines parties en
faire tomber d'autres et donc ça va être
très intéressant de voir qu'est-ce qu'il
va préférer qu'est-ce qui va soutenir
donc pour l'instant c'est pour ça qu'on
est c'est quand même très très bon de
savoir et d'entendre pour l'instant
propose de se tenir aux efforts sur le
climat qui en effet quelque chose que
listrace avait l'air quand même
d'abandonner pas mal donc pour l'instant
on est vraiment dans une situation
encore d'incertitude ou les prochains
jours vraiment compté énormément
sur justement l'international on ne
compte plus évidemment le nombre de
chefs d'État et de gouvernement qui ont
félicité richissounac le Premier
ministre indien d'ailleurs Nora maudit a
adressé ses vœux au pont vivant je cite
que représente les Britanniques
d'originale il a été l'un des premiers
d'ailleurs elle félicité Emmanuel Macron
a félicité richissouna qui l'a promis de
continuer devrait ensemble pour faire
face aux défis du moment dont la guerre
en Ukraine il a donc rédigé dans ce
tweet que vous pouvez voir et Joe Biden
a qualifié de révolutionnaire sa
désignation le président américain a
affirmé qu'il allait s'entretenir avec
lui dans les prochains jours on va
écouter Joe Biden
on vient d'apprendre aujourd'hui
le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
c'est assez stupéfiant c'est un jalon
révolutionnaire et cela compte c'est
important
c'est du fait justement de ses origines
probablement
c'est certainement qu'il avait à
l'esprit en utilisant ce
mot
révolution dans votre pays enfin le mot
révolution n'est pas vraiment très bien
très bien choisi parce que je ne pense
pas que rucher une axe soit lui-même de
tempérament révolutionnaire ces idées ne
le sont pas non plus d'ailleurs à ce qui
est intéressant je trouve entre autre
chose dans son cas c'est que il n'hésite
pas du tout à se réclamer de ses
origines indiennes de sa religion
hindoue a également et de d'affirmer
haut et fort que
ce sont deux éléments constitutifs de sa
personnalité de sa vue du monde
c'est le communautarisme à la
britannique
en France ce serait à peu près
inimaginable quelqu'un s'exprime de
cette façon mais très publiquement c'est
vraiment un autre concept de
la gestion si je puis dire de
l'intégration des des personnes issues
de lieu de de
l'immigration dans la partie
consommateurs il a beaucoup de poids
lourds enfin c'est pas juste symbolique
plusieurs des véritables poids lourds
sont issus de l'immigration mais ce sont
des immigrés qui
se mettent au travail pour s'intégrer
dans la société brique tout en
conservant des attaches avec leur
culture d'origine c'est vraiment un
autre modèle
quand il dit que ces révolutionnaire
c'est vrai qu'en France pour l'instant
on n'a pas de chef d'État effectivement
issu
si on regarde le record des autres poids
lourds comme Paul le dit dans le
gouvernement enfin le dernier
gouvernement de choses et puis Johnson
avant comme pretty Potter
du Parti conservateur et leur politique
notamment par rapport à la déportation
des
des demandeurs d'asile alors
complètement légal il y a rien d'illégal
d'être de demander l'asile en Rwanda ça
c'est eux et soit la brève A1 a dit que
rien ne lui rendrait plus heureuse de
voir le premier bateau partir à Rwanda
donc elle est Matthieu elle a son poste
de l'intérieur
mais ça fait partie de l'équilibre que
richissouna qui essaye de de réaliser
dans son parti il y a une contradiction
là justement quelque part
contradiction je sais pas je
il me semble quand même parce qu'avoir
des ministres comme riches un ou sous la
brève Herman
issu de l'immigration tenir des discours
aussi durs sur l'immigration à d'une ça
me paraît très étonnant ce sont des
personnes qui effectivement nous
annoncent des politiques migratoires
très dures en disant que eux certes ils
sont issus de l'immigration mais il est
important que chacun entre de façon
légale dans un pays ils sont très très
stricts ce sont aussi des brexiteurs ce
sont vraiment des personnalités qui sont
effectivement très durs
ensuite a complètement je pense que on a
vraiment une une vision de la politique
migratoire et qui en effet date déjà
parce qu'il y a une contradiction avec
la politique économique et Origins qui
veulent à relancer la croissance et
autres et une politique à la fois
migratoire qui va être très très dure on
sait que si elle a vraiment par exemple
veut
rendre beaucoup plus compliqué l'arrivée
d'étudiants étrangers par exemple dans
les universités donc on sent quand même
une grosse tension au sens au sein du
parti conservateur et en effet il est
quand même intéressant de remarquer que
pour l'instant les poids lourds du parti
conservateurs à part que la s'agit de
javel ont été quand même
issus des minorités sont au final
vraiment à la très grande droite du
parti poltomson je ne pense pas que
penser que l'immigration devrait se
faire sur la base de la loi est une
position réactionnaire ou rétrograde la
politique au contraire c'est un principe
de bon sens parce que sinon
toute l'idée d'une pays qui est régie
par par ses lois votées par des
représentants etc prend de l'eau
sérieusement et et
à ma connaissance le personne ne porte
conservateur n'est contre l'immigration
en tant que tel la question c'est
comment doit-elle être régulé et dans
quelle proportion faut-il
une question de nombre
pour le Rwanda d'ailleurs il me semble
qu'il est jamais parti finalement
je crois bien non
décourager
du manche c'est de demandeur d'asile un
demandeur d'asile peut pas entrer un
pays illégalement il demande Azil dans
un pays c'est légal et je trouve
franchement un peu et il y a des
hypocrites avec ce système de passeur
qui sont absolument notoire mais ça n'a
rien à voir
ce phénomène un mot sur la relation avec
Joe Biden peut-être avec vous Catherine
Mathieu parce que c'est vrai qu'on sait
que les relations avec Boris Johnson
c'était pas vraiment ça l'histoire
encore moins est-ce que là ça pourrait
changer un peu
semblerait quand on entend la Goldman
Sachs c'est quand même grande banque
américaine il est allé à Stanford aussi
université américaine il a vécu
plusieurs années aux États-Unis
d'ailleurs il lui a été reproché d'avoir
gardé sa carte verte donc il est très
inséré dans les chiffre d'affaires
américains aussi riches unak alors j'ai
l'impression que Joe Biden dans son
discours là nous dit aujourd'hui qu'on a
eu très peur en voyant listrus arriver
avec ses mesures à l'emporte-pièce et
que on voit arriver aujourd'hui
de stablishmone davantage conventionnel
sur le plan financier très anglo-saxon
dans sa façon de travailler très proche
des États-Unis et que donc ça peut être
une relation qui fonctionne bien Viviane
gravé vous êtes d'accord parce qu'en
plus on sait que les origines de Joe
Biden c'est un peu l'Irlande donc alors
je pense qu'en effet le grand test de la
relation sunnac bylen ça va être la
manière dont ils vont traiter l'Irlande
donc on a quand même en avril on va
avoir les 25 ans de l'accord du Vendredi
Saint et donc la paix en Irlande du Nord
et donc il y a des discussions
aujourd'hui de peut-être une visite de
Bayonne à ce moment là pour célébrer
cela
au sein de l'administration de Bayonne
mais au sein d'une manière générale des
institutions américaines il y a quand
même une très grande force des
Américains d'origine irlandaise et
vraiment une un manque de confiance
complet entre la manière dont le
gouvernement britannique gère la
question non irlandaise donc son plus
gros test ça va être au final il va être
quand même beaucoup mieux reçu je pense
en effet parce que il cogne beaucoup
mieux les États-Unis il est peut-être et
l'histoire c'est elle ne connaissait pas
mal les Etats-Unis mettait très proche
plutôt du d'une approche plutôt des
républicains sur les questions
économiques
ce n'est qu'un peu moins mais le il
reste quand même que la question ça
m'étonnerait quand même très fortement
qu'on est une position très
beaucoup plus conciliatrice de oui c'est
une action sur l'Irlande du Nord et donc
je ne suis pas sûr du tout que cette
bonne relation va durer longtemps après
la clé c'est évidemment le brexit
toujours donc cette question du
protocole Nord irlandais sur lequel
était revenu Boris Johnson dont fait
allusion justement en Viviane gravée
est-ce qu'il va rester dans la ligne
Boris Johnson où est-ce qu'il va dire au
contraire on fait table rase comme ce
qu'avait fait listrot c'est on fait on
applique le brexit tel qu'il a été signé
donc avec l'Union européenne qui est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui a sorti un
communiqué en disant ça serait bien que
la Grande-Bretagne le Royaume-Uni
applique effectivement les accords je
suis revenu dans deux secondes mais je
voudrais dire d'abord que je pense qu'il
est un autre dimension qui pèse plus
lourdement beaucoup plus vraiment même
sans commune mesure
avec le brexit ou
l'Irlande du Nord et celle question de
de l'Ukraine
après mais les États-Unis et le
Royaume-Uni sont vraiment un travail de
la main dans la main et ils ont un
projet commun de d'asseoir de renforcer
à la domination de l'OTAN en Europe de
creuser les écarts entre la Russie et le
reste l'Europe pour que la position
l'Alliance atlantique comme on dit
continue jusqu'à l'action on sera dans
la continuité
à réagir la situation aux dépens de de
personnes que Emmanuel Macron qui vise
une certaine autonomie stratégique pour
le droit par exemple et donc ça c'est
vraiment la priorité ici pour le moment
c'est plutôt à ce niveau là
justement
on sait qu'il est brexitter depuis le
début il y a pas eu d'A côté en tout cas
ce que vous disiez sur son
positionnement est-ce que
trouver une solution pragmatique tout le
monde veut une
tout le monde recherche cela
et j'ose pensait que les l'Union
européenne et la République d'Irlande
aussi veulent une solution donc je ne
sais pas dans le détail en quoi ça
consistera mais je m'attends à ce que on
œuvre mais l'espace aussi j'avais ça en
tête de devrait vers
un compromis avec un fort allégement des
contrôles dans la mer du Nord
donc c'est revenir sur les accords sur
le protocole signer ça ce dont vous
parlez
parce que j'en sais j'ai toujours un
travail en cours de recherche d'un
compromis ce que j'essaie de dire c'est
que je pense que les
nouveaux gouvernement est ruchistinaque
vont vouloir trouver un compromis non
pas la sécrétistes empoisonnée les
rapports entre le Royaume-Uni c'était un
peu différent parce que
il a été attaqué assez méchamment je
pense pendant toute les négociations
avant la signature du traité donc il
n'avait peut-être été peut-être tout
prête à aller au clash avec les
Européens je pense que
nous
compromis plus pragmatique
je pense qu'on peut rappeler quand même
que ce protocole Nord irlandais on
savait dès le début qu'il serait une
applicable c'est le protocole la façon
dont les Britanniques et l'Union
européenne ont trouvé une porte de
sortie pour signer un accord mais on
savait dès le début que ça ne marcherait
pas et donc depuis on discute
la mer c'était absolument impossible à
l'intérieur d'un même pays de frontière
entre les deux hommes donc il faut
trouver une solution pragmatique qui
fonctionne il y a des pas qui ont été
faits un des deux côtés pour avancer sur
ce chemin mais effectivement on bloque
pour finaliser le processus et ça n'est
pas certain que riches unach arrive à
débloquer la situation dans les semaines
qui viennent enfin je souhaite pour pour
la paix en Irlande qu'on arrive à
obtenir un accord mais ça n'est pas
certain et surtout la question qui va se
poser je pense très rapidement c'est
cette question évoquée par Viviane tout
à l'heure des normes parce que on
s'était engagé avec listroth à dire que
toutes les normes qui étaient héritées
de l'Union européenne allait disparaître
d'ici la fin 2023 est-ce que
richissenack va revenir dessus ou pas tu
auras un impact très important à
commencer par les entreprises
britanniques qui vendent des
marchandises vers l'Union européenne si
on se met à enlever toutes les
réglementations qui sont là aujourd'hui
ça posera forcément des questions au
Britannique alors justement j'ai vu que
le brexit c'était traduit par une chute
de 15% des britannique vers l'Union
européenne est-ce que en étant plus
pragmatique il pourrait revenir
là-dessus votre avis Nicolas
je ne sais pas je crois que au moins la
grande différence entre Johnson et
sunnak c'est une question de geste et de
rhétorique Johnson était et avait une
rhétorique très confrontationnelle avec
l'Europe mais on savait pas vraiment à
quoi ça allait correspondre concrètement
et je pense que bon richissounax c'est
un homme de la City il veut la
circulation libre des capitaux
donc je crois que c'est probable qu'il
trouve une façon de maintenir le entre
guillemets libre échange en place
pendant des semaines quand il a été
nommé Chancelier d'échiquier à négocier
un accord avec l'Union européenne sur la
question des services financiers là
c'est vraiment le point fort de la City
cette force sur les services financiers
mais du côté l'Union européenne on a dit
afficher
pas de nouvelles accords et on laisse on
laisse britanniques dans l'attente de
savoir si dans le futur on va continuer
à accepter les services financiers qui
viennent du Royaume-Uni dans l'Union
européenne et c'est très embarrassant
tout de même pour Régis une à qui et je
suis d'accord avec vous complètement
pour la libre circulation des capitaux
mais qui se trouve aujourd'hui à avoir
une sorte de mur en face de lui de
l'Union européenne et qui était
totalement brexitor aussi donc Viviane
gravé est-ce qu'il va il va trouver une
solution où est-ce que toute façon on a
encore en train de négocier le brexit
cette question du brexit va continuer à
être une épine
je pense ça va être une épine pendant
longtemps mais ce qui est marrant d'une
certaine manière notée c'est quand même
que l'histoire c'était résa may n'était
pas vrai visiteur et donc on avait quand
même un petit peu un effort d'être plus
royaliste que le roi et d'être de
vraiment montrer qu'ils étaient vraiment
très pour le brexit et souvent jusqu'au
boutiste
Boris Johnson et réfléchi en fait ayant
ce vraiment pouvant se revendiquer du
camp le brexit depuis les premières
heures peuvent en peut être plus
flexible on leur fait confiance sur le
brexit en tout cas les électeurs ont
voté pour le prix leur font beaucoup
plus confiance sur le brexit et donc je
pense qu'ils peuvent être un peu plus
flexibles mais il est quand même je
pense quand même pour cette question par
exemple des marchés financiers on a
quand même plusieurs décisions ou le
Royaume-Uni c'est un petit ray-ball dans
le pied quand même d'un point de vue
même de communication le fait de sortir
des races de fait de sortir
des projets enfin des financements de la
recherche au niveau européen donc je
pense que si il proposait une
coopération supplémentaire renforcée
dans certains domaines ça ouvrirait
potentiellement la porte pour une aussi
donc les marchés financiers mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que c'est d'abord régler
la question du protocole pour l'Irlande
du Nord et ensuite l'Union européenne
est prête à rouvrir d'autres dossiers
des dossiers de coopération avec l'Union
européenne alors que lui il était
probexit
à avoir de bons rapports avec
européen et ça a toujours été dites par
tous les pays dans tous les prénoms mais
c'est une question de volonté des deux
côtés je pense que les événements en
Ukraine auront une incidence aussi parce
que le rôle du Royaume-Uni dans la
défense de l'Ukraine qui est très actif
sur le plan politique et immunitaire et
aussi la constitution du Royaume-Uni par
un groupe de défense dans le nord de
l'Europe avec la Suède la Lituanie etc
c'est très apprécié et là je sais que en
Pologne en Ukraine il y a pas pour
l'instant membre de l'Union européenne
évidemment mais il y a une une volonté
de voir de bons rapports avec le pour
amener mais en France en Allemagne aussi
un certain nombre de personnes qui
estiment qu'il ne faut pas
la fin des temps pour son
père comment le Royaume-Uni s'insère
dans la communauté politique européenne
effectivement sur des sujets de défense
qui sont très importants aujourd'hui sur
des sujets d'énergie on voit bien le
Royaume-Uni entrer dans des discussions
et dans des coopérations avec l'Union
européenne ça pourrait être la porte à
de nouvelles coopérations
progressivement il va durer je pense que
les rapports entre l'Union européenne et
le Royaume-Uni vont s'améliorer
progressivement c'est de l'intérêt
en conclusion
je suis optimiste je pense qu'il va
faire du bon travail et que ce sera
apprécié il sera attaqué
cela mais je pense que il sera tenir
le choc
il va durer ou pas
deux ans je crois jusqu'à la prochaine
élève prochaine élection je crois que
pour le moment
les sondages n'ont pas l'air bien pour
le Parti conservateur en général en ce
moment mais bon ça fait quelques heures
qui les premiers ministres
voilà il a deux ans pour redresser son
parti je crois que le parc du travail
c'était quand même dans une position
très forte pour gagner la prochaine
élection et c'est ça reste la le
résultat le plus probable à mon avis 4e
Mathieu on sait qu'il sera suffisamment
fort pour résister à la pression des
travailleurs et du parti
indépendantistes écossais au Parlement
qui jour après jour vont lui dire qu'il
n'a pas été élu et que pour
continuer à appliquer son programme il
faut qu'il se présente devant les
électeurs britanniques je crois que le
le plus probable c'est que le Parti
travailliste gagne évidemment je oui
dans deux mais il sera chahuté là-dessus
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde est
d'accord merci beaucoup Catherine
Mathieu d'avoir été avec nous merci
Nicolas genre un joli Merci à VOUS
Viviane gravé d'avoir été avec nous en
direct de belles fastes merci Paul
Thompson et merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et vous restez avec nous
sur France 24